a newcastle fan who collapsed in the
stands during their premier league loss
to spurs is reportedly in a stable
condition in hospital well the referee
took the players off the pitch for 20
minutes during that first half to allow
the fan to receive medical attention
one of those who went to help
not him running across the pitch i don't
think dr tom pritchard an a e doctor who
helped treat the fan who we think is
called george at the game uh
tom great to talk to you when did you
first realize that there was something
going on in the stands yeah so
i saw a medley of things going on in the
crowd i wasn't too sure what was going
on but i could certainly see a lot of
fans calling over uh st john's ambulance
and some paramedics so i could see
something going on um so i just kept the
watchful eye on things and when i saw
that someone was down i thought i'd
better get over and offer some help and
advice
so the ref pulls the gay but how how far
away was he and how easy or not was it
to get to him
easy to get to but it was it was a few
blocks away from me uh and when i got
there i had my back to the pitch so i
had no idea what was what was going on
behind me and uh even when i sat down
after uh it had all finished um i was a
bit confused that it was still the first
half i had no idea that the players
actually left the pitch and the game had
been called off
yeah you're just you're too focused on
the on the job in hand um you you're an
any doctor so you're obviously used to
dealing with with things like heart
attacks and stuff and in your day job
but doing it in the middle of the stands
in the middle of all these people how
difficult was it yeah it's quite
difficult so as you say yeah i can be
quite quite used to it in the hospital
but certainly out of hostile i haven't
experienced that that before
it was all very difficult so he was kind
of trapped in between some some seats it
was quite noisy i couldn't hear what the
defibrillator was was telling me um it
was all a bit all of it um different so
it was it was a bit of a struggle yes
but
a plenty of extra support arrived which
was very helpful
well yes there was also a cardiologist
and and the club doctor and john's
ambulance a football stadium is quite a
good place to to have a heart attack
isn't it would appear so so i arrived
then a colleague actually next to me
matti came and came and helped as well
uh the the crowd doctor the official
crowd doctor joe was an intensive care
doctor he arrived pretty quickly we had
as you say the cardiologist arrived in
the crowd as well and the club doctor
came and all ordered offered help and it
was it was well run yeah and you you
mentioned the defibrillator later being
used um you know obviously some
somewhere like a a stadium where there
are a lot of people they're readily
available that the staff who work there
will be drilled and getting them to
people very quickly um but how how vital
was that do you think in insulin
so i would say hats off to st john's and
the paramedics have arrived there and
got the pads on as quickly as they could
that was that was the key here
so early cpr and chest compressions and
early defibrillation is is what saved
this man's life uh when i arrived the
bystander a member of the public had
also started chest compressions and
that's what saved this man a bit like
christian erickson at the euros
everything happening early and quickly
really helps and having
it's such a simple skill to have and
even uh yes i might be one of the
doctors that arrive but i really want to
push for uh public interest and public
knowledge of of cpr and how early cpr
and early defibrillation saves lives and
i've seen since the euros has been a few
campaigns and a few mps becoming
interested in this and there seems to be
defibrillators popping up in shopping
centres and places i think it's really
important that we just we just push for
that now and to help save more lives in
the future
yeah it can really make a difference
before an ambulance arrives um now as as
you
he was obviously taken off to hospital
you went back to your you went back to
your seat um let's just take a look at
this footage this was the reception you
got
[Applause]
the audio was quite quiet but you know
they were saying in their inhibitors of
jordan's hero
that must have been a pretty special
moment yeah well it was a special moment
it was a great feeling that walking back
and having five ten thousand jordies
chanting that at you was uh was
fantastic heading back to my seat there
but i don't want to take the i want to
take the light away from
from what everyone else in that team
contributed it was i couldn't have done
this alone it was the paramedics that i
started early the member of public that
was there as well the two doctors and
the cardiologists that all arrived to
help is what is what made this happen
and i would say that the the real heroes
here were st john's for adding so
quickly in an extremely pressured
environment
well it was great that you were there as
well uh dr tom pritchard thanks a lot
for joining us today and thanks for
talking to us about the importance of
defibrillators